I'm going to start my talk by talking
about a view that's a little bit
different from my own which is a very
optimistic view as well captured by
Shakespeare in particular Hamlet and
what may have been joking when he said
this I'm not quite sure but he M was
famous for having said what a piece of
work is man how noble in reason how
infinite in faculty and that's certainly
a pretty picture of humanity but I'm not
sure it's the right picture of humanity
something like it comes through in the
writings of Steven Pinker who was my
graduate advisor in his book how the
mind works thinker starts that book by
talking about even vision and how well
human vision works I'm going to
absolutely agree with everything that he
said there the most important thing is
that humans have much better visual
systems than a robot does and in fact
all animals most animals have much
better vision that then a robot or a
machine could ever manager it we can
currently manage our visual systems had
been evolving for hundreds and billions
of years and they've really become quite
quite adept at what they do but then
Pinker makes an argument that you might
think of as a slippery slope argument he
said there's no reason to think and
whenever you hear the phrase there is no
reason you might want to put your hand
on the wallet and wonder what they may
be there actually is a reason if there's
no reason to think that the quality of
engineering progressively deteriorates
of the information flows upstream to the
faculties that interpret and act on what
we see so the idea in a lot of
evolutionary psychology is some aspects
of the mind are obviously very well
evolved like vision and our capacity to
reach things and grasp things so I'm
right-handed but Here I am lifting my
teacup with my left hand I have no
problem doing that you can do this even
that could probably be well I'm a
juggler I could probably do it behind my
back if I had to so our motor control
systems the ones that control our
muscles are very good but that doesn't
necessarily mean that the other aspects
of the human mind particularly the ones
that are more recently evolved or
necessarily also well nicely evolved but
before I get to the sort of counter
argument I want to point out the Pinker
is not alone that there are lots of
people in the cognitive sciences that in
one way or another have been arguing
recently that the mind is pretty well
adapted that includes Noam Chomsky is
not particularly a fan of evolutionary
psychology but he has argued that
language appears to be surprisingly
perfect and coming close to what some
super engineer would construct given the
conditions of the language faculty must
satisfy the last parts of the limited
terminology but you get the idea Chomsky
is arguing that language is sort of
mathematically elegant but it's as
simple as you could possibly imagine it
being you can find similar ideas
throughout the technical literature so
my field is cognitive science or
developmental neuroscience depending on
what you want to call it and you see
people making these kinds of optimality
arguments all the time or sometimes they
make arguments lately for something
called Bayes theorem they try to argue
that people are able to approach some
sort of statistical optimum for a lot of
different kinds of things I think behind
most of this enthusiasm except for HAP's
Tom skiing deserves his own reasons
lurks a considerable confidence in
evolution here's a typical quote from
the field of evolutionary psychology
from the fields founders John to the
immediate cosmides they say because
natural selection is a hill-climbing
process and I'll talk about what that
means in a moment it tends to choose the
best of variant designs that actually
appear because of the immense numbers of
alternatives that appear over the vast
expanse of evolutionary comment you
might want to keep the vast expanse part
in your mind
natural selection tends to cause the
accumulation of superlative ly
well-engineered functional designs again
this is quite an optimistic view but
when you look at some of the empirical
facts you might reach a different
conclusion and it's not just the guy on
the left about whom I think all of us or
most of us have our doubts but for
example it's the voters so when you
think about democracy it's a serious
issue that people may have trouble
tracking data keeping track of
reasonable arguments and so forth and I
think it's easy to lose sight of just
how bad human beings are how gullible we
are how bad we are forming proper
beliefs because nowadays we have
something really working in our favor
which is culture and Internet and sort
of spread good ideas very quickly and so
forth but if you just look back a couple
of hundred years ago for the first
hundred thousand years of human
existence people believed in ghosts and
which is an astrology animal spirits
bloodletting all of this kind of stuff
so I don't think that you want to think
of human beings as we machines that are
sort of inevitably guided to the truth
or anything like that we've got our
problems when it comes to reasoning and
thinking about data so I'm not sure
really is reasonable to think of the
human minds being superlative Li Lila
engineered and what I really want to try
to do today is to think about to the
extent that maybe the mind isn't so well
engineered why isn't it
on the basic point of where they're well
engineered
I like what Eris with Bertrand Russell
said to Aristotle basically Aristotle
was famous for saying that man is the
rational animal he was trying to figure
out what's different about human beings
relative to other animals and I think
he's right in a sense which is that we
have the capability of being rational
but we don't always use it's like the
white collar comedian Ron White saying I
had the right to remain silent I just
didn't have the ability we have some
capacity I think for being rational but
that doesn't mean that we're always so
so capable using it and as Bertrand
Russell said all of my life I've been
searching for evidence which would
support this idea that man is a rational
animal certainly we're not consistently
rational so what gives how can we
reconcile the supposed power of
evolution and what it's supposed to do
with the vast expanses of time and so
forth with the manifest clumsiness of
the human mind I mean I give in this
book Cluj lots of examples of where we
do things that are rational and silly
and so forth but the real point of the
book is not just to give those examples
you probably can come up with your own
but to think about why we should find
that why is it so common that we find
different kinds of mental flaws what is
it about evolution the first problem
with this optimistic new that I think is
very common in evolutionary psychology
is it confused it confuses together the
vast expanses of evolution with the
relatively short history of our species
Homo sapiens so it's true that biology
has been involving on this planet for
something like a billion years and some
of our systems have a very long heritage
like our visual systems have been
evolving for hundreds of millions of
years so it's not just humans that have
vision right fish have vision and
octopuses octopi I guess have vision and
so forth so it's very common throughout
the animal world they have vision
evolutions had a long time to manage to
put that together but what about the
things that we think of as sort of
uniquely human the things that Aristotle
was talking about when he was talking
about man as rational animal well brain
systems for conscious thought for
reflection for language those are a heck
of a lot more recent now we're comparing
not not systems that are a few hundred
million hundred million years old but
things that are like a hundred thousand
years old so language and the capacity
to sort of sit around and reflect and
talk about books and stuff like that
that's a whole lot less reason and that
means that evolution has had a whole lot
less time to debug things there's a
second problem here too which is
I think that a lot of people have wildly
overestimated how clever revolution is
of course evolution isn't clever at all
it's a blind process it can't really be
clever
it can just sometimes it can work out
that it produces good results which the
animations not quite right here but
actually the seeming part of the problem
here is that people often think about
natural selection as a hill climbing
process where what what goes on is that
over time things incrementally improve a
little bit so this is Mount Fuji and you
could imagine that there's a that what
evolution is about is basically climbing
to the top of the mountain is a very
common metaphor Richard Dawkins uses it
for example in his book like climbing
Mount improbable into the tooby and
cosmides used it in the quote that I've
described before the idea is that in
certain cases each little each offspring
that you give birth to if it does a
little bit better it brings you closer
to the top of the mountain if it does
worse that that offspring that bears
those genes just doesn't spread it off
so on average over time things tend to
get better in certain ways so you can
imagine for example that a creature that
could see sort of a little bit in a very
squinty way if it gave rise to offspring
they could see a little bit better those
ones that could see a little bit better
their genes are going to spread and the
process repeats the ones that sort of
have black-and-white vision are going to
do better than the ones that have
nothing more than a pinhole camera and
the ones that have color vision are
going to do better than the ones that
have only black and white vision and so
gradually over time you make it up the
top of the mountain and sometimes
evolution really does work that way so a
good example of this is our sensitivity
to light so how much light can you see
in a darkened room well it turns out you
know if you've nothing else to compare
it with you have a dark room you can
detect a single photon of light which is
astonishing that's basically the
theoretical limit you couldn't do any
better so in that respect the human eye
has made it to the top of the mountain
evolution has done very nicely for
itself but there are other respects
where evolution hasn't done nearly as
well I consider the fact that your
retina although it's very sensitive to
light is actually installed backwards so
there all these wires in the front of
your retina that go through the front of
your retinas at the back and so you wind
up with a blind spot this is not good
engineering this is not something that
any sensible engineer would do but we're
stuck with it I'll talk about why
we're stuck within the moment the
problem with the metaphor of evolution
as a mountain climber is that it's
really not one mountain it's really more
like a mountain range so you can think
of evolution as a landscape and what
evolution is doing is it's sort of
picking its way blindly across the
mountain range and what it tends to do
most of the time is it finds one peak
which might be high but not particularly
high and it gets stuck there so we have
the kind of AI that is very sensitive to
light we're at the top of some peak but
on the other hand we have the kind of
eye that has has all these wires going
through the back so we're not at the
best possible eye but we're not going
anywhere either it's good enough and
evolution is sort of I mean if you want
to answer from and throw up the more
flies it evolution is happy with
solutions that are good enough it
doesn't require perfection and if you're
in one place in the mountain range it
might be really hard to get to the other
part of the mountain range well what do
I mean by really hard what I mean is
that evolution is a matter of
probabilities in order to change
something significantly you need a lot
of games to change so you could ask
yourself for example would it be better
for pigs if they could fly whether it be
an adaptive advantage to a pig that
could fly we don't see any flying pigs
but maybe they would be better off
probably they would in fact you know
they could outmaneuver their competitors
I mean imagine that the mates that the
male pig that could fly could get
relative to its you know competitors
that were grounded right it would be
really attractive presumably to the
female pigs you could imagine that the
genes that create flying pigs would
spread around really rapidly and yet we
don't see that right we don't see any
flying pigs well why is that it's
because in order to get that you need
thousands or at least hundreds of genes
to change simultaneously if you just
change say 50 of the relevant genes then
you wouldn't wind up with a flying pig
you would wind up with a pig with
feathers that couldn't do anything with
the feathers or something like that I
mean think about how heavy the bone
density is of a pig and so if you didn't
change the bone density and the feathers
and all this kind of stuff at once you'd
wind up with something that's no better
than its offspring in fact it would look
like a mutant and it probably would have
a lot of trouble meeting mates and so
this kind of thing doesn't happen you
would need to have many many genes
chained simultaneously and evolution
very rarely does that because it has no
foresight it can't say hmm maybe if we
change these 112 genes in particular
none of the others we could get you know
a whole new creature that would be great
evolution can
that so sometimes evolution comes up
with pretty crummy solutions a good
salient example for anybody over the age
of maybe 25 is the human spine great the
human spine works the human spinal
column works it keeps us upright and
that gives us a lot of advantages over
our non-human competitors it also frees
up our hands well that is one of the
advantages but it's a pretty clumsy
design it's an inelegant design it's
certainly not the way that a sensible
engineer would build a bipedal creature
that single column has to bear a lot of
stress and would be a lot better for
example might be a four column design
you can imagine shock absorbers would be
like a car you go over the bumps and we
distribute the load it's not so bad that
would be a better solution but again it
will require evolution to say hey let's
change 100 genes here or 200 genes that
evolution can't do that sorry I missed
the most important word on the slide
which is a kludge occlusions a clumsy or
an elegant solution to a problem that's
where the title of my book comes from
you can think of the human spine that
way it gets the job done but it's not a
particularly good solution clumsy
inelegant and good but good enough
that's my metaphor for the human mind
here's a great example of a kludge I
read the headline for you grad student
both air conditioner on - car - deep
Texas heat right it gets the job done
this air conditioner that you know is
taking the house air conditioner it's
cheaper than having you know the car
dealer in Salem install an air
conditioner and the guy's a little bit
cooler than it would have been otherwise
so it works but obvioulsy reign elegant
this particular solution is so that's a
great example of a kludge another one
some people might be familiar with is
Apollo 13 the mission where they had to
go off to the space capsule the space
capsule didn't have the right air
filters and so it was this great scene
in the movie Apollo 13 where the
engineer says I need you to connect this
thing with this thing using this and he
dumps all of the spare parts there up on
the space capsule onto the table where
where his local engineers in Houston are
and they jury-rigged something together
using duct tape and socks and so forth
it wasn't very handsome as one of the
astronauts said but it worked it got
them home they didn't do they didn't
build their air filters this way because
it was an ideal solution it's not like
they said the guys up on the next
mission with air filters made out of
duct tape and socks but it was it was a
good
sort of stopgap solution which is what
clued Azhar about you might also of
course nobody diver who's maybe the the
greatest kludgy master of all time so he
would do things like he needed some
running shoes but all he had was floor
mats and duct tape and he'd rap to the
floor mats up with the duct tape and
voila he had a pair of shoes this is
where I take a drinking you think of the
other things that my Guyver might have
done famous wine is what would MacGyver
do evolution builds Kluge's for
different set of reasons Engineers build
amusements because they're short on time
they don't have time to plan ahead they
need to get something done the product
needs the ship MacGyver I guess did it
for the ratings I don't know but
evolution built include jizz four
different sets of reasons one of those
reasons is evolution has no foresight
evolution can't look in advance and say
you know this design what the humans
fight it's going to cause problems you
know you compare it to the spine of a
four-legged creature where it
distributes the load over the entire
length and now you've got basically
you've got a flagpole here and you want
to put this big fat brain on top this is
really a bad idea right if evolution
were an intelligent designer like that
wacky guy Ben Stein seems to think this
wouldn't have happened right if this
were an intelligent designer at the helm
and you know before sight and you
wouldn't have that and a dilution also
has no hindsight so we've been stuck
with his bum system for carrying our
weight for a hundred thousand years and
nothing has changed right it's not that
suddenly we're finding offspring with
the four column design because again it
would be too many gains to change and
evolution sort of cheap that changes a
few genes at a time and finally
evolution is always in a hurry so in a
certain sense it's just like the
engineers we need their products to ship
now evolution doesn't have the luxury of
saying you know I've been doing some
thinking the species have been around
for a hundred thousand years it's done
some things well some things not so well
we're going to take it offline for a few
years and you know will renovate will
overhaul will reopen in 2020 right
evolution can't do that in Darwin's
words all evolution is the product of a
process called descent with modification
so everybody thinks of Darwin as being
about survival of the fittest but he not
actually used that phrase and it sort of
oversimplified what he was really
talking about but the phrase he was
really fond of was descent with
modification and what that means is when
something involves it builds on a books
on a framework of things that came
before so there's no sort of Immaculate
Conception in evolution everything is
just modification of the things that
came before and that's because of how
the genes work so the way that your
genes work the genes are sort of a
recipe for building a creature you can
modify that recipe but you can't just
start it from scratch so new stuff is
always built on old stuff and that
extends of course to the human mind as
well as the spine so our spine is built
on the spine of four-legged creatures
that we evolved from and our brains are
built on the sort of framework that was
laid down by creatures that preceded us
another example would be the bird's wing
a bird's wing is basically a modified
forelimbs so you can look around all the
different vertebrate creatures on the
planet and they all have sort of similar
basic designs you take away the feathers
and a bird's forearm is there for bird's
wings basically a forearm so you look
around the animal world it's all descent
with modification as a consequence
evolution isn't really an optimizer I
mean evolutionary psychology is
sometimes written as if what evolution
does is it optimizes the species but
what it really does is it stumbles on
solutions that are good enough and it's
a bit like a tinkerer I always think of
my dad here in his shop Francois Cobb
maybe he was thinking of his dad said
evolutions walk is more of a tinkerer
who often without knowing what he's
going to produce uses whatever he finds
a round of old cardboard pieces of
string fragments of wood or metal to
make some kind of workable object and
that's what evolution is all about well
that's what evolution is all about then
you get what I like to call evolutionary
inertia and I'm making an analogy here
of course the Newton Newton says an
object that's at rest tends to stay at
rest an object it's in motion tends to
stay in motion and by analogy we could
call it Marcus's law an evolutionary
system once moving in a particular
direction tends to continue in that
direction so if there's a single column
way of supporting body weights that
tends to stick around even if it's not
good in the new creature that adapts it
so a single column design as I said it's
fine if you're distributing your load
horizontally is miserable here
descripton distributing it vertically
but because you had the one column
design here and you're tinkering with
that you wind up with a one column
design later even though it's not the
right tool for the job there's kind of a
mismatch between what we inherited and
what we're using include is really about
those kinds of mismatches the idea that
evolution might build Kluge's itself is
not new
so even Jay Gould was very fond at this
point one of my favorite quotes from him
is from the book of pandas thumb where
he's talking about basically occlusions
that the Panda uses to to peel away the
layers of bamboo and he says remnants of
the past that don't make sense in
present terms the useless the odd that
peculiar the in Congress are the signs
of history I think all biologists know
that's all biologists sort of expect
there to be Kluge's but somehow the
importance of Cluj is an evolutionary
inertia and so forth has largely been
forgotten when people talk about
psychology so you see evolutionary
psychology and Time and Newsweek and it
pops up in our culture all the time now
but it's almost always of the form
people say well this must have been
optimal for our ancestors income or
something like that and what I'm trying
to argue is that's not always the case
what I'm going to do in the rest of the
time before we take questions is to give
you an example of that where there's
something that we've inherited from our
ancestors and it's just as inappropriate
as the single columns final design but
we're just as stuck with it because it's
just as ancient it's actually even more
ancient again with the animation here I
don't know what's wrong but this was
supposed to be a subtle hint for you to
look at my book cover but so much for
priming anyway this is where Cluj comes
included it's about three things it's
about the limits of the human mind where
those limits came from and what we can
do about them I'm going to talk I think
in the main part of what's left with
about the limits of human mind and where
they came from and be happy to talk in
the discussion about what we what we
might do about them so as a first
example actually as a main example
consider human memory just about every
creature on the planet uses the same
form of memory I might call it Q driven
memory for other reasons I might call it
shoebox memory but there's a single kind
of memory that we find in all biological
life and before I can explain it to you
I think the best thing to do is to start
by explaining what I think would have
been better and then I'll come back to
the sort of makeshift system that we've
actually got so what would be better I
think is memory it would be organized by
computers and some of you may have done
a little bit of computer programming if
you did even a tiny bit of computer
program what would have learned if the
computers have master maps of memory
everything that is stored in the
computer is assigned to a particular
spot so if you have a 64 gigabyte hard
drive or something like that then there
are 64
I guess it's billion particular
locations
if and every one of them has a
particular basically role assigned to it
and the way that a computer works is you
put something in that spot and it stays
there forever so for example you add a
phone number to your cell phone which is
a computer and you know it's still there
two years later you only have to tell
the computer at once and it remembers it
permanently me I get a phone call
there's no caller ID they leave a
message and they say hey Gary can you
call me back I'm at four to five six one
three eight seven and the area code is
four to seven by the time the person get
to the area code I've completely lost
the number I'm wishing that I had a
piece of paper even more than that I'm
wishing I could remember the code on my
cell phone that would allow me to rewind
to play the message again right human
memory is not cracked up to be able to
learn something like a phone number in a
single trial we often actually need to
hear things many times before we really
learn them my Latin teacher was fond of
saying three times for the normal mind
the idea was if you memorize those
vocabulary words three times it would
spit I think it was a little bit
optimistic but definitely you get the
difference between three and one and
maybe one hundred would be better
sometimes even the most basic things
elude our grasp and come back to the
parachute later but things like where
did I put my keys or where did I put my
car these are easy things for a computer
to remember it's just the last thing
even you just update the particular
location the computer every time the
keys move or something like that
no computer would ever have trouble with
something like where keys were something
like that but the human brain struggles
with this constantly there's a Newsweek
article perhaps in generating saying
something like the average person spends
50 minutes a day looking for lost items
or 15 minutes a week I forget which but
you know it might be an exaggeration but
it's true we spend a lot of time or at
least I spend a lot of time looking for
lost stuff I'll come back to why in a
minute and I'm going to hide that for a
moment the reason that human memory is
not particularly reliable is we don't
have these master maps there's no sort
of organizational system that says this
goes here this goes here I'm going to
put the name that I'm going to put the
phone number that I'm going to put the
address and in computers it's very very
systematic it's all it's all tables
basically nicely organized tables and we
don't have those nicely organized tables
what we have is really something that's
more like a shoebox where you know we
used to have these before the digital
error it's
all your photographs in the shoebox and
be sort of organized like the stuff that
you you know the last set of pictures
from your last negation we tend to be at
the top and the one from the you know
earliest vacation would be at the bottom
but you could never be sure that any
particular memory that you want any
particular photograph that you wanted
would be there and our memories are a
bit like that right you a lot of stuff
is in there in your memories but often
the challenge is to get it out right so
computers can get whatever's in their
memories out very easily but human
beings it's not always the case the
shoebox kind of system that we use goes
under different technical terms is very
very old so this is a great example of
evolutionary inertia it evolved in some
of the earliest multicellular life as a
way of remembering a lot of stuff very
quickly not necessarily specific stuff
but just general tendencies so is there
more food up the mountain or is there
more food down the mountain it wasn't
really about what was it like last
Tuesday on the mountain the animals
didn't need to know that sometimes we do
but in any case that system is now sort
of like the runaway train of evolution
this shoebox memory system has hundreds
of millions of years of evolutionary and
nourisher behind it so it's like the
single column design of our spine we're
stuck with it now it might be better to
have memories that work like computers
but evolution on its own is not going to
change that we can talk in a discussion
about you know whether there might be
genetic engineering techniques or you
know whether to change things but
evolution by itself isn't going to
change it because too many genes would
need to change in order to give us a
memory system that worked more like the
computer's memory so what do we do
instead of location since we don't know
where anything in our brains is really
stored and like no even the best
neuroscientist alive can't tell the
difference between where you stored the
memory for where you put your keys last
week and the memory would be stored for
where you put your keys yesterday maybe
brilliant if neuroscientist can figure
this happen but I don't think even the
brain itself knows that so there's some
things the brain knows that you don't
like your brain can respond to physics
your brain understands the rules of
language even though you can't say what
the rules of language are but your brain
apparently can't tell the difference
between where you put your keys last
week and where you put your keys today
because you stumble you'd have trouble
with it and you stick around with
irrelevant information right it doesn't
matter
where you put your keys last week right
all that matters is where your keys are
now I don't care where you parked three
days ago I don't care where you parked
two days ago I just care where you
parked this morning but all that stuff
lingers in our memory we use clues to
try to get stuff out and so we're like
basically gets translated into brain
language like where did I put my keys
recently and you get flooded with all
these memories well you know one day you
put it you know by the table another day
you put it on the desk and I thought of
that in the actual memory that you want
doesn't always come up um so my strange
animation now sorry about that so
suppose that I asked you for example who
was the 16th President of the United
States that's a kind of fact that's easy
for computers because they can memorize
table so some do types up a list of all
the presidents means feels it from the
Almanac puts it into Wikipedia and it's
there forever it spreads throughout the
internet nothing you know it won't
change unless some you know somebody's
playing a goof or something like that
someone who sees this talk and wants to
have some fun so Wikipedia now has that
information permanently and probably
most of you learned it in grade school
who was the 16th reading or you probably
memorized the whole list somebody showed
it to you but you probably have no idea
what the 16th President of the United
States was you might even struggle for
the century a century of when that
President lived so then I can give you
another clue and maybe that helps maybe
it doesn't so for me the clue that would
help beside the dead giveaway clue that
I'll give you in a second is he was a
good writer there are only so many
presidents that are good writers George
W Bush not among them and so you can
narrow it down and that and that helps
the you know a more happy if you have
more precise clues in your memory is
able to cope better um eventually if
that does he do it for you I tell you
something like he freed the slaves or he
looks or he's the dude with the long
beard and the tall hat and then
everybody realizes it's Abraham Lincoln
but the point is the information about
Abraham Lincoln is in there but we
sometimes have trouble getting it out
and what we do we use all these cues and
all kinds of bizarre consequences like
here's one you're all sitting down right
now will you remember this talk later
when you are standing up or lying down
or swimming not as well as if you're
sitting down when you try to remember it
so your posture is one of the many clues
that you're desperate brain uses to
remind itself of the stuff that it
learned before another famous study
looked at scuba divers they memorize a
list of words while they're underwater
and then they get tested a couple days
later
and if they're underwater when they're
tested they remember it better than if
they're on land despite the fact that
you know when they're underwater they're
like you know trying to remember to
breathe despite that distraction still
being underwater helps them to remember
things better because the brain doesn't
really know what's relevant or not it
just takes every cue puts them all
together and hopes for the best
this needless to say is not an ideal
system certainly doesn't work as well
with something like Google it can lead
us to lots of trouble so for example a
computer can put what we call a time
date stamp on any memory so every time
you update a file on your computer it
says you know last changed on April 17
2008 or something like that it would be
nice if we had that an intelligent
designer probably would have labeled our
other membranes that way but if I asked
you like what year was the OJ Simpson
trial you know you heard this trial
every day for like six months and most
people wouldn't be able to remember when
the trial actually happened you might be
able to reconstruct it you could say
well let's see it was in college I
hadn't met my wife and you can kind of
fake it you can kind of work your way
back to when it happened you don't just
remember it and then you have things
like the Shawn Bell trial that's
happening in New York now where the
police shot somebody on a subway in
front of like 50 eyewitnesses they
interviewed last week a couple years
later all those eyewitnesses they
basically had 50 eyewitnesses and 50
different stories like couldn't even
establish basic facts like did the guys
don't say something to the police
officer before the police officer shot
oh so the kind of memory that we have
where all these different things respond
is not such a good thing for eyewitness
testimony people can't sort out what
they actually saw happen from the stuff
that they thought about afterwards or
friends asked them about it the lawyers
asked them all that stuff blurs together
were terrible that I was testimony or
consider skydivers I had this up before
and I bring it back when we do something
over and over again we lose track this
is why airplane pilots are crazy if they
don't use checklists and I think most of
them aren't that crazy in fact and I
certainly wouldn't want to fly with an
airplane pilot who didn't fly with a
checklist cause otherwise like you ask
yourself a question like did I put up
put up the landing gear and if you've
asked yourself that question 100 times
has he flown a hundred times you might
well confuse the one time in which you
didn't with the 99 times in which you
did because that's how our memory works
again if all of these different things
they're all coming with
QS you don't have any specific time date
stamps and so you could easily forget so
I actually went and did a little
research on skydiving deaths and it
turned out 6% of them can be triggers a
lot when you think about it can be
traced to people forgetting to pull the
rip cords what's going on there
people think they pull the rip cords
because their memory is failing them
they're remembering other times when
they pulled the rip cords and the
consequences are devastating matic the
flaws in our memory extend well beyond
what it is that we can recall so I mean
it's sort of obvious in a way that our
memories are bad that turns out that the
fact that evolution built the rest of
our brains on top of this kind of clumsy
system of memory has really really
serious consequences and I'll give you a
few examples one is it makes us totally
vulnerable to spin-doctors so my
favorite example of this thought that by
some fiendish republican is the death
tax right people pretty much like estate
taxes death taxes they hate an estate
tax is that's you know who has the
state's rich people the rich people pay
enough do they pay their share and that
it's okay we'll charge them when they
die the death tax it's like awful right
what does that make you think of that
makes you think of death which itself is
like a raw deal right I mean it's
totally unfair that we should have to
die and then you're going to charge
somebody after they die what a total [ __ ]
so the one on the left sounds awful and
you know nobody would support the idea
of a bath packs the one on the right
sounds pretty good the problem here is
that they're the same thing but it's
really really hard for us to think about
them as the same thing it's really hard
for us to get over that what people call
the framing of things another favorite
example of mine is the soap you know
it's 99% pure that sounds great it's
almost like organic I'll take three and
then you think for a second you're like
oh but that's one percent toxic maybe
I'll put it back on the shelf and the
point is that we just see those labels
or 80% you know 80% lean versus 20% fat
the stuff comes up over and over and
over again it's called framing why does
framing matter so much it's exactly
because cues drive everything that we
remember there's a great phrase in
computer programming which is garbage in
garbage out so you could imagine a GPS
system having all its trigonometry right
all its satellite communication right
but having a bad
app right if it had a bad map you know
if they change the rows it has an
updated the maps then it's still going
to give you a bad result and I think a
lot of human reasoning is that way we we
can sort of do the rational thing if we
think of the right data but we often
don't think of the right data because
these little trivial differences in
wording and so forth affect which
memories we happen to come up with and
unlike a computer that can sort of
systematically search a database we're
basically stuck with the first thing
that pops into our head and once we work
really hard to fight that this also has
consequences I'm afraid for scientific
reasoning so as a species were very
vulnerable to something called
confirmation bias what that means
essentially is when something fits with
a theory that we already have we notice
it we write it down or we tend to
believe in it something doesn't fit we
have trouble remembering it so when it
comes to evaluating your favorite
hypothesis who's your favorite deity or
you know whatever it might be who's your
favorite political candidate for the
Democratic Party you think of all of the
things that match your theory so you
have a theory that Obama is better
because he inspires passion and you
think of 13 reasons why passion would be
a good thing you don't think about any
reasons why Clinton you know bla bla bla
I mean I'm on the Obama side so I'm not
going to give you give away the things
you might think about if you were on the
Clinton side but the point is none of us
as a matter of natural course really
thinks about the data on both sides
equally what we tend to do because of
the structure of our memories is the
theory is a cue it makes us retrieve
particular things that match that theory
we're not so good at looking at the
things that don't match that theory
another example of that you can sort of
skip all the text David another example
of that is you can ask a bunch of people
that share an apartment who what
percentage of the dishes do you do one
person might say 50% another says 60 the
third one says 52 and so forth I
guarantee if you ask that question add
up the numbers they will add up to way
more than 100 right you'll never find
some household where everybody actually
gives the numbers that really represent
the amount of dishes that they do and
why is that well it's a function of
memory accessibility and it's also a
function of the fact that we don't
realize how our memories work so it's
inevitable that you're going to remember
the times that you did the dish is
better than the time that you know your
girlfriend did the dishes because your
girlfriend did the dishes you're not
even there and you're not thinking about
it and so forth but the real
problem is that people don't
automatically compensate for that right
the way to get along with your roommate
is to realize that there might be some
occasions that you don't remember but
our brains aren't really set up to do
that to take a third example I think the
acute driven memory or shoebox memory
whatever I'm calling it contributes to
mental illness so for example the state
the urine this is like the stuff with
the scuba divers influence is what you
remember so if you're in a depressed
state you wind up thinking about more
things that are depressing so you have a
fight with your boss you come home you
start playing some blues music you start
listening to breakup songs and you know
it's just a it's a spiral or what I call
out ruminative cycle and the next thing
you know somebody can really wind up
depressed the same thing happens with
with paranoia and I would argue that
suicide is actually an example of what
statisticians call a post-op Maxima
which is where you look at sort of the
last piece of data or the most extreme
piece of data and you base all of your
conclusions on that data instead of
looking at the statistical distribution
as a whole our brains are not good at
looking at statistical distributions as
a whole and I suspect that I don't
really have the data that people that
commit suicide to sort of do it on the
worst day and they're not taking what
what we call a moving average of the
data of their lives by just saying like
oh my god this is so bad they're
focusing with this room as a cycle on
all the bad things they're not taking
into account too long review and so I
think this is another consequence that's
not at all optimally designed but
another consequence of the structure of
our memories I think and this will be my
last example the structure of human
memory may explain why human languages
aren't as precise of computer languages
so you could think about all the
languages in the world and you could
talk about the set of languages that
humans actually speak this is something
that Chomsky has often talked about when
talks about universal grammar and the
idea is the decided human language is
just one small set of possible languages
yes Russian is different from English
but if you look at Russian and English
as compared to say computer languages
all the human languages over here and
all the computer languages are like
something totally different and then
could imagine mathematics those are sort
of like computer languages and then you
could imagine invented languages like
Klingon and there are people that like
go to immersion classes to learn these
things and Klingon is probably different
from any other human language though I
am NOT an expert fluent speaker in
Klingon but so you can imagine this is
space of possible languages then you can
ask this question why do human languages
have the properties that they do
and I'm just going to consider one
property now let's talk about others in
the book consider ambiguity just about
every human language that you can think
of has what you might call inadvertent
syntactic ambiguities that the grammar
is not clear are we talking about the
spy the Chop when we say the spy shot
the cop with the revolver are we saying
that the cop had the revolver or this
guy or the guy is about the spy had the
revolver that's another kind of language
Cluj when we can't articulate a sentence
with too many thoughts in our head at
the same time but that's I say for
another day so or the sentence like put
the cup on the towel on the table is is
the cup on the towel or is the towel on
the table these things are ambiguous we
usually don't notice them because
context helps make it clear but they
happen all of the time as computer
programmers realize when they started to
try to understand that and detects the
people type we often don't realize when
we are ambiguous so there's a wonderful
experiment that asks people to read
sentences like put the cup on the towel
on the table and just say does the other
person in the room understand what
you're saying and people wildly
overestimate the extent to which other
people understand the ambiguous
sentences and in fact I find one of the
most valuable tools and writings is a
heightened sensitivity to ambiguity so
that you can realize when your readers
might get in trouble but that doesn't
come naturally that takes a lot of
practice again I am continuing the theme
of skydivers and accidents this kind of
thing can among other things that lead
to things like plane crashes so there's
a famous example where something like
580 people died because the Mission
Control of air traffic control said
where are you and the pilot said at
takeoff and that was ambiguous did it
mean that he was he'd already taken off
and he was in the air or he was about to
take off there was a difference of
opinion and two planes collided
so I'm serious business lots of
philosophers have noticed this problem
that languages are subject to in
beginning I'm not talking about the kind
of ambiguity where you say somebody says
would you like to go out on a date and
you say well and you try to kind of hem
and haw on your you're deliberately
ambiguous I'm talking about these
accidents where that can lead the plane
crashes or just lead to miscommunication
I submit to you that your average human
being couldn't learn an ambiguous
language even if he or she tried my
evidence for this was a great experiment
that we did in 1960 testing something
that's known as a worse hypothesis the
idea behind the word hypothesis is did
the language that you speak
would affect the way that you think so
the famous example which turned out to
be a bad example was that hope these
speakers allegedly didn't have words for
time and so the idea was they wouldn't
be able to think about time if they
didn't have words for time the
experiment has a sort of sad end which
is that the guy who made this
observation didn't realize that Hopi
speakers actually did have words for
time but the sad story I can tell you
another time this guy James Cook Brown
what he wanted to do was to kind of pick
up on what Russell and liveness and
other philosophers had said about
language being ambiguous and that
leading to what we call equivocation
where people make bad arguments because
the language isn't clear it said okay
here's what I'm gonna do it's 1960
computer programmers have been at this
for a little while we know now and
mathematicians we know now how to make
an unambiguous language people like
girdle and Carnap and all these guys had
figured out how to make nice formal
languages
he said I'll teach people this perfect
language and I'll test the Whorf
hypothesis if their language is perfect
then they'll stop making all these silly
errors that human beings make it was a
great idea for an experiment and I urge
you to read this 1960 Scientific
American article it's still a classic I
think there's only one problem with this
ambitious plan the professor Brown had
which is no human being was ever able to
actually learn this language log when
you read the website like people are
still trying they have pathetic things
like we were able to speak on the
telephone for 15 minutes after studying
for three years and this is obviously
not as natural with it to humanity as
say English or Chinese or Japanese where
people can learn in a relatively quickly
I think that imposing that kind of
perfection on a human language ie
getting rid of the ambiguity might be
like forcing a square peg on to a round
hole in mathematical terms it's very
easy to get rid of ambiguity right all
you need is parentheses it's like
boneheaded ly simple all you need to be
put some parentheses and then is it
parentheses the sky the spy a shot or
the spy shot parentheses the cop with
the revolver do I put my parentheses
somewhere else but we're reduced to
doing stuff like this with the
parentheses and a little quote marks and
stuff like that we don't actually have a
way of putting that in our language I
think that's because our memory systems
wouldn't be able to handle it we can't
remember what happened two seconds ago
in perfect reliability as you add more
clauses to a sentence things get more
and more complicating people get more
and more confused so our languages
I probably allow ambiguity simply
because our brain structures wouldn't be
able to hack it otherwise so I'm going
to summarize and then take questions in
many ways the human mind is the crown
jewel of evolution but that doesn't by
any stretch make it perfect or even the
best compromise of it imaginable saying
that the human mind is perfect at some
things like vision or near optimal or
whatever you want to say doesn't it all
mean that we're near optimal in all
respects right there's a little side
thing here that I'm going to mention
because Ben Stein is in the news
we're not the product of intelligent
design there's this movie out trying to
say that you know scientists won't talk
to people who are interested in
intelligent design I'm happy to speak to
those scientists I'm sorry to the to
those advocates of intelligent design as
a scientist I'm happy to speak to them
and what I'll tell you is that every
example that I just gave you is an
example of unintelligent design if we
are the product of intelligent design we
would certainly have a better memory
system and a better spine some of our
mental machinery is elegant but a lot of
it I think with a little foresight could
have been a lot better I have a whole
other sort of set of things I might talk
about about what we might do about this
but I'll save them for now allow you to
ask whatever questions you like I thank
you very much
sir so two quick comments first on
language ambiguity I really like the
title of your book specifically because
and I'm assuming you're aware this Cluj
has kind of a fraternal Siamese twin
clued with a D was in terms of the
orthography in terms of the spelling
yeah yes I build it over time and I like
the fact that includes that d is a very
clever design what people have gotten
the word confused for the oh I think
you're miss a pretending the literature
over visitant in the etymology but it's
an interesting question so there are two
ways in which this word is spelled one
would it be in one without a determinate
at all well people argue about that so
yeah so one theory is that clues the way
that I spell it actually owes something
to the word clever because it's a German
word khloga
which means clever and you can see how
certain Kluge's are clever like the guys
who are on the space capsule or MacGyver
you know figuring out how to do this in
like 10 minutes with spare parts with
band-aids and duct tape and all that
kind of stuff that's pretty clever and
so it may be that the origin of the word
somehow relates to the German in terms
of the spelling I sort of made a
tactical choice here i my heart is
actually with spelling it with a D
because if that in itself is more clumsy
and more inelegant but I thought if
you're going to dare to have a book with
a title that nobody knows what it is it
might be even riskier to have a title
that nobody knows how to pronounce and I
thought that people might rhyme rhyme it
that way with sludge and I'd rather that
they rhyme it with students which i
think is closer to to you know the
pronunciation of Coolidge and the intent
so there's there's some interesting
questions there other questions well one
other question and that's a very quick
one um I read a study some at some point
recently where they were testing whether
complexity goes away or complexity tends
to just add and it seemed like it was
only in the direction of adding it
mostly moat in that direction right for
kind of the sorts of reasons that I'm
talking about which tends to be easier
to sort of add something on them to take
it away and sort of prune it down to it
it's element evolution can simplify
things it can get rid of stuff too but I
think on average what it tends to do is
to
new stuff on top of old stuff so I think
there's a general tendency towards
complexity but like I don't know like
you have blind mole rats that you know
live in caves and eventually they lose
their vision and eventually that system
may become simply because there's no
adaptive pressure on them to have vision
anymore and so the neural circuits that
are involved in vision might sort of
drop out over over a great deal of time
other questions yes do you have any
thoughts as to what causes deja vu and
what we cynical people who don't enjoy
that feeling can do about it eliminate
not exactly sure what causes deja boo'
but I think that it's it's a matter of
all these cues and overlapping memories
so you get something that's sort of
almost a perfect hit you know something
that reminds you of circumstance before
and you get this kind of funny feeling
down your spine they don't know exactly
why it is but I think it's again because
like if you had precise control over
your memory you could say well actually
come to think of it this is like what
happened before you know in these three
respects but it's actually different in
these two other respects and Thank You
brain for reminding me that if they're
similar but you know I can see the
difference between the two but because
our memories are in this sort of
fragmented way with no time date stamps
and all this kind of stuff you can't
quite sort it all out and I think that
gives you an uneasy feeling you have I
seen this before or have an AI seen this
before so that's my theory about it
anyway what they're all science
questions are still intriguing you
keeping you interested I think in terms
of sort of sheer neuroscience in terms
of brain science I think there's this
basic question of how we represent
abstract knowledge in the brain so we
know a lot in neuroscience about where
things are in the brain so we know for
example that the amygdala is involved in
emotion and we know that the hippocampus
has something to do with memory and so
forth but we really don't know how many
of those pieces of neural tissue do
their thing and we especially don't
really understand that much about like
the mechanics so how in particular
memory is represented like we can say if
I cut off from CT synthesis it won't
happen there won't be any memories of
their form we have no idea sort of what
the code is the way in which it's all
encoded and so if I could you know solve
any research problem that's available
that would be the one it's a very
difficult one I don't actually
anticipate tell me but that's a problem
that might get solved in my lifetime
I think is really deeply interesting and
unsolved the other thing I would really
really like to know not on the brain
side but maybe on the more the
psychology side is there's this deep and
interesting question why is it that
human children are so much better at
learning languages than human adults I
mean let alone chimpanzee so why is it
that your average four-year-old can you
know go into a new culture pick up the
language like in the summer and me if I
went off to you know Spain for a year
you know be lucky if I could conjugate
the verbs I have some thoughts on that
question that don't really have an
answer to it and I think that's another
one that's you know deserving of sort of
what they call big science budgets you
know huge budgets to try and actually
answer it this is a lot of practical
consequences that we could teach
languages better thank you you first oh
no oh I better trust the book trust in
the bloom anyway could you speak of a
human memory being well designed with
the brain being well designed and so
forth or poorly designed properly but
that's a normative term well designed
and your explanations albeit obviously
as a purpose of one but what one needs
to ask is how do you define what would
be a well designed system as against a
poorly designed system and why do you
think for example the human memory would
be better designed if it was designed
like a computer memory well I think you
could even look to understand that I
think that you can look to things like
Google as an existence proof how
something could be better could be more
effective so I mean certainly there's
room to argue that the human mind has
been optimized for what it is so for
example given that we don't have perfect
control over our memories we're pretty
good at remembering the things that
happened frequently and other things we
will you want to remember the frequent
thing so you know you want to be able to
remember your wife's name because you
use it very often it would be really sad
if you couldn't remember your wife's
name you use it often it comes to mind
very quickly it would be nice if you
could remember the name of the kind
person that introduced you at the talk
but if you've done eight talks in six
days as I have them that sort of thing
becomes hard if it's low frequency then
you're not really able to do it so the
in comparison to Google Google can do it
all right it can do PageRank it can say
this is the most common hit but it can
also get you need of it what's the word
the Google wax the thing where there's a
single hit and the entire you know
entire web so Google can kind of do it
all it can do the low frequency and the
high-frequency more generally Google can
do the same kind of things that we can
do which includes responding to cues
handling sort of break down so we our
memories have a sort of graceful
degradation so if you go drinking you
lose a few neurons it doesn't hurt that
much you know you lose a few neurons but
most of your memories until you you know
drink too much and get Korsakoff
syndrome most of your memories remain
intact and that's partly because I think
our memories are represented redundantly
we have multiple copies or something
like that Google takes that trick too so
there are many servers that have copies
of memories and so if the network is
down in one place can still come up with
the answer so Google kind of combines
the best of classical computer memory
design in terms of having location
address ability where you can say you
know this thing is stored in this
particular spot with actually this set
of spots with all of the advantages of
human memory so it's it's possible
somebody could make an argument that it
would be better to have this kind of
clumsy memory than we do but I really
don't see the argument myself yes both
biology and computer science and
technology are moving onward so do you
see at some point that we might be able
to tinker with our shoebox memories and
make them better
I absolutely it's a very interesting
question I wrote about it in the New
York Times two weeks ago in the Sunday
magazine I think that we could do a lot
to learn something from Google so I
should preface this by saying that I
think evolution has sort of on its own
steam reached the end of the line with
human beings for two reasons we've got
birth control and we've got very good
medicine which means the people who do
stupid things that would earn what we
used to call Darwin Awards often can
survive people that are not very bright
and can reproduce and sort of out
reproduce people that might be brighter
and so forth I'm in a different criteria
but so I don't think natural selection
is going to change for example the
structure of our memory on its own again
too many genes would have to change
there's not enough selection pressure
because of various things they're going
on but there's a very good chance that
people will take take this sort of
evolution or this sort of problem into
their own hands so you can think about
like people give human growth hormone to
first you know
gave it to children that were abnormal
what does it normally challenged in
stature right and eventually people
start taking human growth hormones
because they want to do better in the
NFL so you get these kind of things that
are initially basically there as
remedies for problems and then people
sort of push them harder and harder in
the case of human memory it's not so far
away that we can imagine two different
kinds of things that we could do they're
sort of external interventions that
might improve human memory one is that
we might use brain implants and the
other is that we might do some kind of
genetic engineering thing so both of
those things sound really scary to most
people but I think that there are going
to happen some people won't do them but
I think it's sort of like burying our
head in the sand like the ostrich if if
we look we're just in denial because of
the thing like human growth hormones
right some people will want to do these
things some people will be like mmm if I
buy this brain implant for my child
my child will get straight A's and get
into Harvard sooner or later somebody
most of us will be a gap you would put
this little brain chip in you drop it
but some people will be you know they're
looking for an edge and the technology
is not that far away because we already
know how to build brain implant well not
we but like Richard Anderson and Caltech
for example there are people who know
how to build brain implants they're not
using them from memory yet as far as I
know but for example there's a lot of
work in that area and the area of brain
implants in terms of dealing with spinal
injury so people have built brain
implants that allow monkeys to control
video games using basically their brains
rather than their hands as no joystick
the monkey just thinks the electrodes
read essentially what the monkey is
thinking and that controls the joystick
moving left to right so that that's
that's not the whole technology but it's
a start and I think you know we're just
now we're just arguing about into 20
years of the 50 years it's a hundred
years it's going to happen that people
are going to be able to bring build
these things and then on the genetic
side you know one of the big news
stories earlier this year was Craig
Venters allow team created an entire
genome for scratch and it was a tiny
little genome it was for a bacterium but
you know as Richard Anderson said in the
Six Million Dollar Man we have the
technology so it's going to happen
would you have any excusing would you
have any advice for owners of kludgy
brains - how to pedicle how to cope yeah
actually the last chapter of the book is
all about that so I think of the phrase
from Alcoholics Anonymous recognition is
the first step so the first thing that
we have to do is to realize that our
brains are clueless except that once we
do we can say well there are some things
that are kludgy about our brains that
probably not worth fixing like because
our memories are poor we can't calculate
square roots in our head we would get
lost with all of the sort of
intermediate numbers so what use the
calculator it's not a big deal but there
are other things that we do that are
coogee that can be fixed and they're
worth fixing like we're very poor at
thinking of two sides to a hypothesis
but people who go to graduate school and
learn that in fact I think children can
probably be learned is there's some
advices I give in the back of the book
that I think some people think is banal
but actually all of this advice has good
empirical evidence behind it so for
example you can train yourself to think
about alternative hypotheses it's
difficult because of the way the
context-dependent memory works so you
know the first thing you will do is you
try to train yourself to think about
alternative hypotheses it's you'll do it
when you're in lecture rooms that are
like this or something like that you
will do it in exactly the same
circumstance but you will forget to do
it you know when you're out lying on the
beach you won't think of priming maybe
you don't need to on the beach maybe
that's a poorly chosen example but you
will forget to do it you know when when
you're at home and having conversation
with your roommate even though it would
really benefit your interaction if you
would be fair to your roommate and think
of alternative hypotheses but we can
practice anything that's one of the
virtues of in mind so just like you can
you know learn to improve your golf
swing if you really work at it you can
learn to improve you basically your
habits of reasoning and start to think
about alternative hypotheses in a more
systematic way the second side to this
so I give I think 13 suggestions for
what you know any individual might do
the second possibility the second
implication I should say is I think we
should actually change our schools in
reflection of the reality that we have
kludgy brain so we teach our children
about digestion but we don't teach them
how the brain works instead we spend
most of the time getting them to
memorize facts so we get them to
memorizing them all over the components
of the digestive system one again they
could look them up in the Wikipedia may
or may not be important for them to know
we don't teach our children that much
about how to think about thinking or
what we call medical
but there's some good recent studies
that show that you can actually do that
their studies with 10 and 11 year olds
where the children are introduced to a
book called Haring stottlemeyers
discovery and what Harry Otto Meyers
discovery is it's thinking he's asked to
write an essay about his favorite thing
and this boy is clearly after my own
heart
writes about thinking and he says well
thinking is a very interesting thing for
all of these four reasons you can think
about your thinking you know the
electromagnetism is cool and says that
my words not is electromagnetism is cool
but you thinking about thinking that's
that's where it's really at so this is
curriculum where kids read this kind of
stuff they're basically learning
philosophy the Tennant road rolls and
helps their verbal scores
it helps their self-confidence and so
forth so I think a lot of these skills
are trainable so if you recognize that
our brains are coogee and you work hard
to develop habits that respond to those
I think you can as I say at the end of
the book learn to outwit your inner Cluj
I should probably put in a plug for my
very own podcast which will debut
I hope this week have called outwit your
in inclusion the idea is I'm going to
have people submit their own suggestions
what can you do with if you have a
clumsy memory you know do you put your
keys by in a jar by the door or whatever
you're you know do you memorize acronyms
like ROYGBIV for red orange yellow blue
green violet you know when the cameras
are there it's hard to remember it so
I'm going to try to start a little forum
where we can all work together to out
with our inner Cluj I teach the book
calm then probably have to cut that from
them take any other questions come on
last question
okay so then to kind of have a sort of
cynical view on everything and giving
things that you don't agree Racal yet
optimistic yeah okay so then given what
you just said would you agree that our
brains are I guess designed to be as
rational as possible well I mean the
first thing I would say is that they're
not designed at all and the second is
that we can be rational with training
but it's not a natural thing I think of
rationality as being a little bit like
leading as opposed to language so my day
job is about how children acquire
language and the thing about that about
acquiring spoken language is every child
does that naturally doesn't matter what
culture they grow up in it's just it's
like breathing or walking language comes
naturally reading is something that
people
a lot of training for they don't just do
it naturally they've got to go to school
for it if they're not in the right
culture then it doesn't happen and I
think that logic and reasoning is like
that you can train people to do it you
can send them to graduate school maybe a
good undergraduate school might teach
them that but it's not something that
comes natural it takes a lot of work so
I wouldn't say at all that were
naturally rational I'd save it because
we're good at picking up habits and
doing that in a very general way we can
acquire the tools to be rational but I
wouldn't say that anything like
breathing or that it's automatic and I
guess that's it thank you all very much